workers are busy reconstructing the
hector martinez building in the center
of saradena last month a car bomb
exploded destroying much of this block
dissidents of former fire rebels are
being blamed for the attack which killed
one person the buildings house human
rights groups social organizations and
unions
we were holding a security meeting
because of the way the conflict was
evolving with direct attacks against
social organizations and community
leaders
the farc dissidents are accusing us of
sympathizing with the eln and that's how
they justified attacking us
arauca an oil-rich region on the border
with venezuela has been mostly calm
since the signing of a peace deal
between the government and farc rebels
in 2016.
but violence returned as farc dissident
groups began to fight eln rebels for
control of drug trafficking and
contraband routes
since the beginning of the year more
than 60 people have been killed others
kidnapped or forcibly displaced
delgado sister of security guards
delgado killed in the explosion says
locals are terrified
this war is absurd and my brother is
just one of many victims everybody is
anxious because we don't know what will
happen tomorrow
even on a quiet day people can't sleep
can't rest well they fear leaving their
house everything has been affected
normally at 6 30 p.m the streets of the
center of saramena would be alive with
people shopping but since the conflict
started shops are closing early and
people are hurrying home fearing another
possible attack and on top of that the
mayor has imposed a curfew every night
starting at 9 pm
the government has increased its
military presence in the area
the violence has pushed more than a
dozen health workers to quit after
hospitals were also threatened by the
groups
catholic priest albert geraldo is
holding healing sessions to help workers
deal with trauma
he says part of the problem is that the
military is mainly protecting the oil
infrastructure in a region long
neglected by the government
it's a problem that goes back in history
the government has always prioritized
protecting military infrastructure
instead of the people the church has
asked the president to reopen the door
to a peace dialogue with the eln there
was supposed to be a meeting in
stockholm the government didn't go we
are also trying to talk to then
dissidents but we are on our own
for hundreds have left others like sonia
lopez promised to rebuild and continue
their work for the people even if it
might cost them their life alessandra
al jazeera